نتابع هذه التطورات بالمزيد من التفاصيل
والمعلومات مع ضيفنا من الخرطوم السفير
عبد الرحمن خليل ناطق الرسمي باسم
الخارجيه السودانيه اهلا بك معنا مع علي
السفير الى هذه التغطيه المستمره للتطورات
وللازمه السودانيه اسمح لي ان ابدا معك
بعمليات الاجلاء جوا ما هي اخر التفاصيل
وما هي المطارات خاصه المؤمنه والمتاحه
لنقل رعايه الدول المختلفه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والتحيه لقناه
العربيه والساده المشاهدين
[موسيقى]
في توفير المطارات وتوفير الممرات الامنه
والتسهيلات لكل الامور اللوجستيه التي
التي تستخدمها الدول الدول لترحيل
الرعاياها سواء كان اذونات الطائرات او
حمايه القوافل التي تنقل
الرعايه والدبلوماسيين الاجانب
وتوفير كل التفعيلات الممكنه لهم في هذه
الحاله ولكن من يؤمن برا مثلا حدثتني عن
تامين هذه القوافل عن طريق البر وحضرتك
تعلم بانه من الخرطوم الى بورتسودان هناك
العديد من الساعات عشر ساعات تقريبا صحح
لي ان كان هنا خطا في هذه المعلومه عشر
ساعات هناك الشبكات على امتداد هذا الطريق
من يؤمن وصول القوافل من الخرطوم الى
بورتسودان الجيش او هناك استعانه بمنظمات
اخرى
القوات المسلحه السودانيه هي التي توفر
الحمايه لكل الله لكل القوافل التي تتحرك
من من الخرطوم الى الى بورسودان
طيب وبالنسبه للجو بالنسبه للمطارات قلت
حضرتك بان هناك مطارات نوفرها نؤمنها
لتمكين الدول من
محاوله على الاقل هبوط طائرات ومساعده
رعاياها هذه المطارات يمكن ان نسميها
بالطبع ممكن ان نسميها وكثير من الدول
اجلت راعيها
عبر المطارات العسكريه
عبر مطار
ما هي قلت لي بانه لا حرج في ان نسميها ما
هي هي هذه المطارات اعطينا لمحه على
تامينها كيف يتم
كل المطارات العسكريه التي
هي مطارات معمره تماما
طيب هذا بالنسبه للمطارات
هل اخرى
تفاعلت معكم او
تواصلت معكم
بخصوص رعاياها بخصوص عمليه الاجلاء
كل الدول كل الدول
اتصلت وتواصلت معنا بخصوص ايجار اياها وهي
تختار الطريقه المناسبه سواء كان ترسل
طائرات تهبط في المطارات العسكريه ومن ثم
يتم تعميم نقل المواطنين المواطنين
والرعايه الى تلك المطارات ام عن طريق
الحافلات التي تتحرك من الخرطوم الى
بورسودان وعدد كبير جدا من السفارات يعني
يعني نظمت عمليه ترحيل عن طريق البر من
الخرطوم الى بورسودان وتم تامين هذه
القوافل الى ان وصلت الى بورسودان ومن
هنالك
اما تستغل الطائرات اما تستقل السفن
الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه ومنها الى
الوجهات المعنيه انتم كوزاره خارجيه سيد
خليل هل لديكم احصائيات او اعداد دقيقه
ومحدده لاعداد الدبلوماسي ين والرعايه
عموما الذين غادروا السودان منذ بدايه
الاشتباكات
الاعداد متغيره يعني كل يوم
يتم ترحيل اما ان يكونوا في طريقهم الى
الترحيل
فيصعب تعبئه وضع رقم محدد في هذه اللحظه
الى ان يتم عمليه الترحيل ولكن يعني معظم
معظم الدول الاوروبيه
والدول العربيه
نستطيع ان نقول يعني اكمل
الدبلوماسيه ولكن هنالك بعض بعض الرعايه
الاجانب يعني لم يتم حتى من الدول الغربيه
الامريكيه لم يتم
ترحيلهم ربما ربما ربما يكون في الخطوه
الثانيه الدول الاسيويه الان كلها في
طريقها اما عن طريق البر واما وصلوا الى
بورسودان وفي بعض الدول ما زالت تجمع
رعاياها في مناطق محدده وتنفق عمليه
ترحيلها الى بورسود ما صعوبات التي
تعترضكم في عمليه ترحيل سواء برا او جوا
الصعوبات تتمثل في الخروقات التي تقوم بها
القوات المتمرده من حين لاخر
وتعترض طريق
القوافل احيانا
مثلا
الفريق القطري ولا القافله القطريه يعني
تعرضت تعرضت لبعض
الهجوم ولكن يعني استطاعت القوات
السودانيه ان ان تحميها وكذلك
القافله الفرنسيه هو متجهه الى احدى
المطارات العسكريه في الطريق تعرضوا الى
بعض
المناوشات من قوات
التمرد التي تسعى الى التقريب والتعرض
للدبلوماسيين وممتلكات الدبلوماسيين
اتخذ ايضا من وتتخذ ايضا من المواطنين
دروعا بشريه
هذا هذا ما يقوله الجيش السوداني ودعم
السريع كذلك في المقابل يتهم بنفس الاتهام
هو تصريحات تاتي من الجانبين ولكن سيد
خليل في هذا الاطار
البعض يلاحظ بان اليومين الاخيرين كان
هناك زخم في عمليه اجلاء رعايه وهنا كانت
هناك قراءه بان الايام القادمه بعد عمليه
اجراء كل الرعايه ستكون ايام صعبه سيشتد
فيها القتال حضرتك بحسب خبرتك الدبلوماسيه
هل هذه القراءه دقيقه
لا لا احد يستطيع ان التوقع بما يحدث في
الايام القادمه ولكن لكن القوات المسلحه
السودانيه تؤدي دورها وفي قمع التمرد
واعاده الامر الى نصابها والانتهاء من هذا
الوضع الشاذ لقوات
الدعم السريع المتمرده سيد خليل هل حقيقي
بان هناك مسلك لمحاوله التفاوض مع الدعم
السريع فتحت بشكل او باخر فتحتها جهات في
الداخل او في الخارج تتواصلون او هناك
وساطه
يقوم بها احد الاطراف
هنالك جهات عده عرضه الوساطه لكن قبل
انتهاء هذه هذه المهمه يكون يكون
ليس ليس ليس هنالك فرص للتفاوض اقل انتهاء
هذا الوضع الشاذ وردع التمرد
وقمع المحاوله الانقلابيه
ان كان اكد بان هناك جهود امريكيه سعوديه
اماراتيه مصريه لطرح نوع من الوساطه ماذا
في تفاصيل هذا الموضوع سيد خليل
كل الوساطات ليس ذلك فحصت وان عدد من
الدول الافريقيه والدول المجاوره كلها
طرحتها وفاته ولكن لكنها يعني تطلب في
البدايه وقف القتال
ومن بعد ومن بعد يمكن التحدث عنه او
التفاوض ولكن
هذا وضع شاذ ولا وفي محاوله انقلابيه
وتمرد من جهه من جهه عسكريه لا بد من
القضاء عليها ومن ثم بعد ذلك كان يكون
التفاوض
من الجهه اللي قادره ان تؤثر او على الاقل
ان تطرح وساطه ومبادره فعليه تقبل من
جهتكم من جهه
الجيش السوداني
الوصفات كثيره
وجهات كثيره مؤهله لذلك
ودول صديقه ودول
دول دول مؤثره العالميه ولكن هذه هذه
المبادرات اذا لم تاتي في الوقت الله اذا
لم يكن في الوقت وقت المناسب او النقطه
المتاح قبل
بحسب قراءه حضرتك ما الوقت المناسب
الوقت المناسب هو القضاء على التمرد
لماذا اخفق وقف الاقتتال تماما لماذا هذه
الهدنه الاخيره مثلا اخفقت في ان تتوقف
الاشتباكات ان يتوقف الاقتتال تماما ليطرح
فيما بعد شكل من اشكال المبادرات
بسبب بسبب الخروقات المستمره
لقوات الدعم السريعه المتمرده للهدنه
محاوله
تحسين مواقعها وكسب اعراض جديده وتحسين
والتموضع في اماكن استراتيجيه والتغلق
داخل داخل المراكز السكنيه والمرافق
العامه
لاتخاذها دروعا دروعا
تختبئ وراها من من من من قوات المسلحه
السودانيه
طيب اود شكرك جزيلا شكر كنت معنا من
الخرطومه سفير عبد الرحمن خليل الناطق
الرسمي باسم الخارجيه السودانيه شكرا
جزيلا لك لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات